alors vous voyez la réaction de la
population on voyait qu'ils obéissent
sans chercher à en savoir plus
alors je vous présente des daniel c'est
votre nouveau camarade de place j'espère
que vous serez lui faire bon accueil
comme il se doit
on devrait
nouveau pas trop chaud soleil des
tropiques les coaches sélection turque
c'est non
ma vie pour tous pas adéquat a relancé
sa non les voit de toutes les couleurs
il est ainsi fort ah si ce que tu veux
dire tu parles mal socialiste a demandé
[Musique]
bien sûr le faisons la réunion fleuve
c'est la victime était trop de sens et
non pas la même chose qu'au passe au
dessus attends attends resort and spa
salut salut factor on n'a pas caché
depuis un centre dédié au milieu des
miens lymphatique quelque chose puis à
nouveau le rapport
ah bon alors on est sympa tu peux
carrément dire que c'est un petit
prétention qui sera meilleur que tout le
monde à bon droit que les gens du chaton
surtout steak tartare s'en servait non
sérieux il a osé 8 tout ça juste parce
qu'il nous a vu aux infos il avait les
maîtres mal à nous proposer sauvage
bonjour je vous amène une nouvelle
recrue entre reportages sur le quartier
oui j'ai cru comprendre qu'il y a une
conversation un peu animé hier dans la
cour de récréation
mssa fathi ben j'ai parlé avec et agnel
et je crois que le meilleur moyen pour
lui de découvrir le quartier c'est de
participer à votre projet quoi mais il
ne propose des ouvrages et bien
justement il verra par lui-même que ces
paroles étaient un peu déplacé n'est ce
pas italienne oui monsieur ali bon je
vous laisse vous organisé entre vous bon
travail
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est fascinant champ centre si c'est
pas du parc on s'améliore ça va lui
apprendre quelques trucs
salut les gars sont excusés la suite un
petit coup d'oeil sur le montage c'est
ça que je voulais simplement faire je
sais c'est sa voix c'est bon j'ai rien
fait mais ce que je racontais les choix
on ne touche pas c'est un match qu'on
doit maintenant
aujourd hui on a eu un souci avec
l'ordinateur souci
et encore
non c'est bon et tania lima remis le
film ce matin je vais essayer tout est
bon bon oui pas de soucis d'ailleurs
toute la classe est là pour voir le site
allez-y vous attendez vous
[Musique]
d'ici là s'il autorise ou non
g
d'après marie pascal bugis bas il n'y
avait pas d'étonner mariage c'était pas
mon truc comme ça c'est pas mal du tout
autre
le parquet était que désertent la
piscine les immeubles aussi dû
construire 10
elalamy la ville l'église s'est vu
confirmer mes yeux parce que le petit
crocodile pour la place c'est un
quartier de la réunion quand il est
parti à saint robert
comme partout sauf quand il ya des gens
pour des conneries n'avions pas été bons
et on a tendance de longue date y en a
tendance à regarder les aspects négatifs
de pattes ailées janvier la vie dure et
ben y'a pas de garder des dents très bon
gardien
voilà c'est surtout un grimpeur ou être
on peut parler retourne sans qu'ils
aient des instances un mode et attire
vrai trailer on a des rêves opposants
devant la natation
moi j'ai tremblé bien que celui là
dessus on a envie d'avancer
mais c'est un bon nous on a honte voilà
rôle à fond ce sens en décembre
j'avais mal ajustée
[Musique]
à la mauvaise réputation qui est un
petit peu véhiculée par les médias
eh bien on est bien c'est encore un
quartier qui a beaucoup changé
ça fait
le collège jules
et tribaux respecté aux tags
dégradations en tant que professeur g
un certain lien affectif avec ce
quartier j'aime beaucoup les élèves
d'ici quartier alors je pense que
l'aspect positif c'est que c'est un
petit quartier où il ya une forte
identité où les gens se connaissent les
uns les autres et
son prêt à céder
bon
a dit que je venais habite où je
voudrais
c'est vrai
dans un quartier salle personne
tu tape dessus mais en fin de compte non
trop pas j'aime bien bureau
je passe à table
et pas
cas des choses qu'il faut changer
genre tout est codé
regardez
on a besoin
malgré les inconvénients qui passe à la
télé
alors moi j'aime bien le quartier car
c'est ici que tout article parcours
sur cette base ainsi que j'aime
oh
moi j'aime bien mon quartier parce que
c'est familial qui avait soutenu par ma
confiance à gbagbo a changé donc
bah c'est landreau qui grandit avec tous
les bons coups
moi j'aime encore des parce que tout le
monde se connaît on est tous sympas les
uns les ors des friqués parfois ils
raisonnent pas mais
toujours par ses partenaires
alors on dit souvent que le show dont 6
tirs et on n'y a que distraire
tout ça mais justement c'est grâce à ce
que j'ai je commençais attendu par tous
s'amuser aussi dans la ville
quand je marche pour racheter 10 1
pouces avec ma famille
et bayrou
il sort mais
même si ça c'est pas ça le choix
d'habiter d'or et
on s'habitue aux à grignan et aux bonnes
choses il ya plus de bonnes choses
convenablement votre m
c'est là tu vois
c'est un quartier comme les autres sauf
qu'il n'ya pas de racistes tout le monde
s'aide et vraiment je trouve ça je suis
content de crise
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]